bueno intentamos hacerlo brevemente como
saber que este es un litigio que tiene
casi 24 años
[Música]
bueno ha pasado por prácticamente todos
los todas las jurisdicciones
internacionales y también algunas
jurisdicciones en varios países empieza
en 1993 en eeuu después de que los
afectados ecuatorianos decidieron
demandar acebrón cuando ya había
abandonado el país recordemos que fue
texaco quien operó en la década de los
sesenta 70s y 80s en el ecuador y en
1992 empacó sus cosas y se fue alto
seguido fue demandada en el 93
este juicio empieza con el juicio de las
comunidades afectadas del ecuador contra
texaco en nueva york' y durante nueve
años
texaco litigo para que el juicio sea
enviado al ecuador en el foro más
conveniente según ellos y se
comprometieron a aceptar la sentencia
que emita más cortes ecuatorianas en el
entretiempo también hubo una fusión
entre entre chevron y texaco mediante la
cual la empresa sobreviviente fue llevo
es por eso que cuando el caso fue
desestimado en eeuu y enviado a ecuador
la sentencia se planteó contra chevron
ya que sus abogados personalmente habían
aceptado que la compañía se iba a
someter a la jurisdicción ecuatoriana
bueno ahí nomás ya pasamos nueve años de
litigio
luego en ecuador tenemos que sumarle
otros 10 años más hasta hasta obtener 19
años
la decisión de primera instancia y 10
años más hasta que en 2012 la corte de
apelaciones ratifica el fallo del
inferior con una condena por daños
ambientales daños a la salud años a la
cultura de los pueblos indígenas que
llegue que sobrepasa los 9 mil 600
millones de dólares
en ese punto
los ecuatorianos intentamos embargar
todos los bienes que se habrán tenía en
el país todavía nos encontramos con la
sorpresa de que habían dejado solamente
360 dólares en su cuenta bancaria y no
tenían ningún otro bien con el cual
cumplir su obligación judicial ellos se
fueron de ecuador ellos se fueron de
ecuador ellos vendieron todo lo que
tenían entonces para la fecha que fueron
condenados con una sentencia
ejecutoriada cap capaz de hacer
y cobrada mediante los mecanismos
judiciales abiertos ellos ya no tenían
nada en el país nos habían dejado le
digo 360 dólares y un daño ecológico
enorme y un año ecológico enorme sobre
400.000 hectáreas un perdón más de 450
mil hectáreas en el año se sigue
expandiendo porque eso sigue ahí
enterrado y esto afecta a más de 30 mil
personas entre las cuales cabe destacar
la presencia de cinco nacionalidades
indígenas diferentes